how's it going everybody it's Warren
welcome back to my channel the cosmic
wonder where we talk about all things
relating to Marvel everybody is
expecting anticipating and waiting for
the venom to teaser trailer that was
supposed to be here by now
in fact very reputable sources such as
deadline.com have claimed that the
trailer is on its way and should be here
within the week
now unfortunately due to the coronavirus
studios are a little bit hectic right
now however there appears to be some
possible good news a supposed photo from
the trailer has apparently arised and
this could be very big news because if
this photo is legitimate that means that
the venom 2 trailer could be here any
day now and I'll explain why if you're
new be sure to subscribe to stay up to
date on all things Marvel and so you can
enter my giveaway for a chance to win an
Xbox one or ps4 I'm picking a winner at
five hundred and fifty thousand
subscribers so it seems like Sony has
kind of found their own unique way to go
about releasing their teaser trailers
Marvel has their own unique way of
releasing trailers as well such as in
the trailers there's usually something
taken out or something added in using
CGI and it appears that Sony has found
their own thing to do and that would be
leaking photos from the trailer right
before they come out if you recall right
before the Morbius teaser trailer came
out they leaked a photo of Morbius and
in the background on the wall was a
picture of spider-man with the word
murderer over it now this was definitely
a tactic that Sony was doing this got
everybody hyped up for the official
trailer of Morbius and now they're doing
the same thing with the venom 2 trailer
leaking this photo now we know what this
is based off of everything that we've
heard and all the footage that we've
seen so far this is Cletus Kasady riding
around in his car the cops are chasing
him Eddie Brock is chasing him as well
in this photo he has the carnage
symbiote with him and we know that
because of two different reasons one is
because a description of the venom 2
teaser trailer has leaked and it says
that at the end of the trailer a cop
opens fire on Cletus Kasady but the
carnage symbiote catches the bullets and
the second reason is we have actually
seen this with leaked photos of filming
on the set so in this leaked photo the
carnage symbiote is with Cletus Kasady
at the time and it appears that we are
going to
be seeing the carnage symbiote by the
end of the teaser trailer and this is a
relief because it's something that
people have been worried about because
we didn't really see the Venom symbiote
in the venom teaser trailer if you
haven't had a chance to hear the leaked
description of the trailer yet I'll link
it up above and I'll put it in the
description down below for you to check
it out but due to this photo being
leaked and due to some major sources
like deadline.com reporting that the
trailer is coming soon hopefully that
means that we don't have to wait much
longer so let me know what you think in
the comments down below also don't
forget to like the video and subscribe
to stay up-to-date on all things
relating to marvel and a venema to as
always thank you all so much for
watching willful